Everybody knows the holidays can be stressful. And so with the holidays upon us, we thought, you know what would be nice? An hour of jokes. Let's do an hour of holiday jokes. But reflecting on this for about 10 seconds made us realize there's actually no such thing. Think about it for a second. What is your favorite Christmas joke? Right? Even kids who love Christmas and love jokes do not have Christmas jokes. To be sure this is true we actually ran a scientific test this week where we asked a group of kids to tell us their favorite Christmas joke.
大家都知道假期可能会带来压力。随着假期临近，我们想，什么样的主意不错呢？一小时的笑话。我们来做一小时的节日笑话吧。但仅仅思考了10秒钟，我们就意识到，其实根本没有那种东西。仔细想想。你最喜欢的圣诞笑话是什么？对吧？即使是那些热爱圣诞节和喜欢笑话的孩子们，也没有圣诞笑话。为了确定这一点，我们本周进行了一项科学测试，我们要求一群孩子给我们讲他们最喜欢的圣诞笑话。
OK. Hmm. I don't really know one. Can they go first?
好的。嗯。我真的不知道一个。他们能先来吗？
One of our producers, Jonathan Menjivar, went to the playground at New York's PS 11 asking third graders for Christmas jokes. And while none of them knew any Christmas jokes, it turns out that all of them were willing on the spot-- apparently any third grader will do this-- they were willing to make up Christmas jokes.
我们的一位制片人乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）去了纽约PS 11小学的操场，向三年级学生索要圣诞笑话。虽然他们中没有人知道任何圣诞笑话，但事实证明，他们所有人都愿意当场——显然任何三年级学生都会这么做——他们愿意现编圣诞笑话。
Why did the reindeer cross the road?
驯鹿为什么要过马路？
I don't know. Why?
我不知道。为什么？
To get to the horn station.
去角站。
You know, the horn station.
你知道的，角站。
The horn? What's a horn station?
角？什么是角站？
Where they get new horns.
他们获取新角的地方。
Oh! That makes sense sort of.
哦！那倒也说得通。
Yeah.
是的。
I don't know if you could hear that. One of the kids in the background goes, "That makes sense." And everyone then agrees.
我不知道你们能不能听到。背景里有个孩子说：“那说得通。”然后每个人都同意了。
--sense? I'm not sure I understand.
——说得通？我不确定我理解了。
Because reindeer have horns and then they need new horns.
因为驯鹿有角，然后他们需要新角。
Yeah. And then sometimes reindeer if they get their antlers broke off, they grow back in, and in this joke, they go to a store.
是的。而且有时候驯鹿如果把鹿角撞断了，它们会重新长出来，在这个笑话里，他们去了商店。
Here's another one.
再来一个。
There was a chicken that's running around like crazy on Christmas Eve. And then Santa came. And it's like, "Hey, Santa! Can I go on?" Then Santa's like, "You can get on the deer, but not on my head!"
有一只鸡在圣诞前夜疯跑。然后圣诞老人来了。它就像说，“嘿，圣诞老人！我可以上车吗？”然后圣诞老人说，“你可以上鹿身上，但不能上我的头！”
Why does Santa get married with a skinny woman?
为什么圣诞老人要娶一个瘦女人？
Yeah. I feel like the setup is often the best part of these jokes. Why does Santa get married to a skinny woman?
是的。我觉得这些笑话的铺垫通常是最好的部分。为什么圣诞老人要娶一个瘦女人？
Because Santa feels bad that he's so fat and she's so skinny. And he wants to see somebody that's skinny.
因为圣诞老人觉得他自己太胖了，而她太瘦了，他感到很难受。他想见一个瘦的人。
I'm glad to say though that some of the jokes the kids made up on the spot did actually have the structure of real jokes and worked as real jokes, with punch lines that actually made actual sense.
不过我很高兴地说，孩子们当场编出的一些笑话确实具备了真正笑话的结构，并且作为真正的笑话发挥了作用，那些笑点确实有实际意义。
Why didn't Santa deliver the presents?
为什么圣诞老人没有派送礼物？
I don't know.
我不知道。
Because it wasn't Christmas.
因为还没到圣诞节。
OK. This next one was told to Jonathan by a little kid who first explained that they don't celebrate Christmas. They celebrate Hanukkah with the Hanukkah menorah and all that.
好的。下一个笑话是一个小孩子告诉乔纳森的，他首先解释说他们不过圣诞节。他们庆祝光明节，有光明节灯台之类的东西。
What does the Christmas tree say to the menorah?
圣诞树对灯台说了什么？
I don't know.
我不知道。
He says, "You don't have decorations like me. I'm more popular than you."
他说：“你没有像我这样的装饰品。我比你受欢迎。”
It's funny because it's true. Jonathan wasn't sure what he should say to this little Jewish kid about that joke.
这很有趣，因为这是真的。乔纳森不确定他该对这个犹太小孩说什么。
Wow, the Christmas tree is mean.
哇，这棵圣诞树真刻薄。
The Christmas tree is mean, but the menorah actually has good intelligence.
圣诞树很刻薄，但灯台其实很有智慧。
Good as these jokes are, fact is, if you want a Christmas holiday special that's filled with jokes, you really have to go to professionals. And so in preparation for today's show, we went to stand-up comedians and performers and we put them on stage in little clubs and venues, wherever they like to try out new material over the last few weeks. And today, from just a small club with I think 200 people in it, we bring you our Comedians of Christmas special. We have some people who you've heard of on our show before, like Mike Birbiglia, but lots of amazingly funny people who you may not know. We have actually never tried this before, and it's been completely exciting seeing what happens when we throw a theme like Christmas to these really talented, funny people.
尽管这些笑话不错，但事实是，如果你想要一个充满笑话的圣诞节特别节目，你真的必须去找专业人士。所以为了准备今天的节目，我们找到了单口相声演员和表演者，在过去几周里，我们把他们安排在小俱乐部和各种场所的舞台上，让他们试讲新材料。今天，在一个我想大约有200人的小俱乐部里，我们为您带来了我们的“圣诞喜剧演员”特别节目。我们有一些你们以前在我们的节目中听过的人，比如迈克·比比利亚（Mike Birbiglia），但也有很多你们可能不认识的、极其有趣的人。我们其实从来没试过这样做，看到当我们把圣诞节这样的主题抛给这些非常有才华、有趣的人时会发生什么，这真是太令人兴奋了。
And so, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
所以，来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续收听。
Act One, Christ Has Prison.
第一幕，基督在监狱。
We were worried that was a little too Eastery. It's a Christmas show.
我们担心那太像复活节了。这是一个圣诞节目。
Wyatt Cenac is a correspondent and a performer for The Daily Show with Jon Stewart . And he has this story about spreading Christmas cheer in Texas. Please welcome him.
怀亚特·塞纳克（Wyatt Cenac）是《乔恩·斯图尔特每日秀》的通讯记者和表演者。他有一个关于在德克萨斯州传播圣诞欢乐的故事。请欢迎他。
Thank you. I am from Texas.
谢谢。我来自德克萨斯州。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
That's not normally the response I expect. Its very weird because when you tell somebody that you're from Texas, their response is, "Oh my God, I love Austin!" Which is cool, but I grew up in Dallas. And people will be like, "Oh, I'm sorry. Austin's pretty awesome. Austin's great."
这不是我通常预期的反应。这很奇怪，因为当你告诉别人你来自德克萨斯州时，他们的反应是，“哦，天哪，我爱奥斯汀！”这很酷，但我是在达拉斯长大的。人们会说，“哦，抱歉。奥斯汀挺棒的。奥斯汀很好。”
It's weird. I've lived here in New York now for about two and a half years, and I was actually born here. I lived here as a baby. And it's nice to be back. The city has changed a lot since I lived here as a baby. When I was a baby, everywhere you went it was just colors and shapes everywhere. Gentrification has changed all of that. In my old neighborhood, I remember on the corner there was this amorphous yellow blob. Now it's a Chipotle.
这很奇怪。我现在在纽约住了大约两年半了，其实我出生在这里。我小时候住过这里。回来感觉很好。自从我小时候住在这里以来，这座城市发生了很大变化。当我还是个婴儿时，你所到之处到处都是色彩和形状。绅士化改变了这一切。在我原来的街区，我记得拐角处有一团无定形的黄色东西。现在是一家Chipotle快餐店。
When my mother hit her 50s, she went through a bit of a midlife crisis. And typically, a midlife crisis is something that people associate with men. Men who are struggling with getting older, they maybe go out and buy themselves a Corvette or some other type of penis car. And my mother didn't do that. What she did for her midlife crisis was she went to church wearing those big fancy church lady hats that star in Tyler Perry movies.
当我母亲步入50岁时，她经历了一点中年危机。通常，中年危机是人们与男性联系在一起的东西。那些在衰老中挣扎的男人，他们可能会出去给自己买一辆科尔维特或其他什么类型的“阴茎车”。但我母亲没这样做。她中年危机所做的是，她戴着泰勒·派瑞（Tyler Perry）电影里那种抢眼的教堂女士帽子去教堂。
You see, a man in a midlife crisis maybe goes and gets himself an old Mustang and soups it up. And my mother did the same thing. She would take these hats, and you'd see her at church on Sunday with a bunch of other middle aged ladies. And they'd have tricked these hats out with lace and ribbons and flowers and dodo eggs, whatever they could get their hands on. They'd put rims and a spoiler on there if they could. And this is what my mother did.
你看，中年危机的男人可能会给自己弄一辆旧野马并改装一下。我母亲也做了同样的事。她会拿这些帽子，你会在周日看到她和一群中年女士在教堂里。她们会用蕾丝、丝带、花朵和渡渡鸟蛋，任何她们能弄到的东西把这些帽子装饰起来。如果可以的话，她们会在上面装上轮毂和扰流板。这就是我母亲所做的。
And in the same way that when a man goes through a midlife crisis, he might find himself a trophy girlfriend, some 20-year-old who will spike up his hair and put him in ill-fitting T-shirts that have sparkly dragon skeletons on them. My mother did the same thing. She went to church and she found herself a trophy boyfriend named Jesus Christ.
就像男人经历中年危机时可能会找一个奖杯女友一样，某个20岁的女孩会把他的头发弄得竖起来，让他穿上印有闪亮龙骨架的不合身T恤。我母亲也做了同样的事。她去了教堂，给自己找了一个叫耶稣基督的奖杯男友。
And when you think about it, Jesus is really the best trophy boyfriend for a menopausal woman. He's older, but he doesn't show it. He doesn't care if you feel like you're aging and you've got crows feet or you feel bloated or anything like that. He doesn't care. He loves unconditionally. If you want to spend all day in aerobic slippers, guess what? So does he. That's his uniform. Oh, and the most important one. He's made of bread and wine. He's perfect.
仔细想想，耶稣确实是更年期女性最好的奖杯男友。他年纪大了，但看不出来。他不在乎你是否觉得自己老了，是否有鱼尾纹，或者是否感到臃肿之类的。他不在乎。他无条件地爱。如果你想整天穿着健美拖鞋，猜猜怎么着？他也一样。那是他的制服。哦，最重要的一点。他是用面包和酒做的。他是完美的。
And around the same time that my mother started seeing Jesus, the church decided that this Christmas they were going to do some Christmas prison ministry. And what they were going to do is they were going to take Christmas gifts to prison inmates. And my mother loved this idea, so she signed up.
就在我母亲开始见耶稣的同时，教会决定这个圣诞节他们要做一些圣诞监狱事工。他们要做的是带圣诞礼物给监狱囚犯。我母亲很喜欢这个主意，所以她报名了。
And you might be asking yourself, What kind of Christmas gift do you give to a prison inmate? I mean, their list is probably pretty simple, it's probably just freedom and sex, not necessarily in that order. The church couldn't deliver on those things, so they thought the next best thing would be a bag of fruit. And what it was, it was a paper bag that had been decorated by the children of the church. They drew little pictures on it. And then inside that bag was an apple and an orange and a little prayer card. Because it's church, nothing's free. And then on the flip side of that card was a calendar, which really seems like the worst thing you could give a prison inmate as a gift. That's the Christmas prison equivalent of some kid waking up on Christmas morning to find a pair of socks when he has no feet. But at the same time, it's the thought that counts.
你可能会问自己，你会给监狱囚犯什么样的圣诞礼物？我的意思是，他们的名单可能很简单，可能只是自由和性，不一定是这个顺序。教会无法提供这些，所以他们认为下一个最好的东西是一袋水果。那是一个由教会孩子们装饰过的纸袋。他们在上面画了一些小图画。袋子里有一个苹果、一个橘子和一张小祈祷卡。因为是教会，没什么是免费的。那张卡片的另一面是一个日历，这看起来真的是你能给监狱囚犯的最糟糕的礼物。这相当于某个孩子在圣诞节早晨醒来发现一双袜子，但他却没有脚。但同时，心意最重要。
And my mother was doing this thing. It was very noble. Not everybody would go and give Christmas to prison inmates. I thought, wow, that's really awesome of her that she wants to do that. I'm going to do something nice for her. So that morning, I figured I was going to wake up and I was going to make her some pancakes because she's got a big day ahead of her.
我母亲在做这件事。这非常高尚。并不是每个人都会去给监狱囚犯送去圣诞礼物。我想，哇，她想这样做真的很了不起。我要为她做点好事。所以那天早上，我想我要醒来给她做些薄煎饼，因为她前面有忙碌的一天。
And that's when I found out that my mother would not be going to the maximum security prison. My mother had never had any intention of going. See, she liked the idea of doing a Christian mission, but she also liked the idea of spending the day in bed watching Wheel of Fortune. And since she couldn't do both, she decided she would send me to prison in her place. It was at that moment of my life that I understood what outsourcing was.
就在那时我发现我母亲根本不会去最高安全级别的监狱。我母亲从来没打算去。你看，她喜欢做基督教传教的想法，但她也喜欢整天躺在床上看《命运之轮》电视节目。既然她不能两者兼顾，她决定派我去监狱代替她。就是在人生的那一刻，我明白了什么是外包。
My mother decided to send me, my little brother, and my stepfather, who up to this point had been OK with the open relationship that my mother, he, and Jesus had been having. And we get out to the prison. And if you've never been to prison, the first thing that happens is you take off your Santa cap, because you feel silly. It doesn't seem right. And it's like everything you've seen in movies. There's a big buzzer that's like, errr, and some guy's like, "Come on through!" And you do that and then there's a caclunk of the door and all that stuff. And we do all that, and we're inside the prison.
我母亲决定派我、我弟弟和我继父去，直到现在我继父对我母亲、他和耶稣之间正在进行的这种开放式关系还觉得可以接受。我们到了监狱。如果你从没去过监狱，第一件事就是你要摘下你的圣诞帽，因为你会觉得很傻。这看起来不太对劲。就像你在电影里看到的一切。有一个大蜂鸣器发出“呃……”的声音，有个家伙说，“进来吧！”你就那么做了，然后门发出“咔哒”一声，诸如此类。我们做了所有这些，我们就在监狱里面了。
But what doesn't happen most times in the movies or an episode of NBC's Lockup is because there was a thunderstorm going on, there was like big flash of lightning and then this really loud thunder crack. And then the power went out. Yeah. It was just darkness in prison. And at the time, the movie Jurassic Park was big. And all I can think to myself is, [BLEEP], the raptors are loose and all I have are these apples to defend myself. The oranges I'll keep to fend off scurvy. But the apples. And then eventually the power comes back on, and everybody's fine. I have to pick up some of the warning apples that I threw out.
但在电影或NBC电视台《锁闭》节目中通常不会发生的是，因为当时正在打雷，有一道巨大的闪电，然后是巨大的雷声。然后电源断了。是的。监狱里一片黑暗。当时电影《侏罗纪公园》很火。我脑子里能想到的就是，“操，迅猛龙跑出来了，而我手里只有这些苹果来保护自己。”橘子我留着防坏血病。但苹果。然后最终电源恢复了，每个人都没事。我得捡起我扔掉的一些警告苹果。
And we're doing this. We're giving Christmas to these guys. And in prison they tend to separate the prisoners and categorize them in different ways. And there are the guys who are in solitary confinement. It's called the hole. They're considered the worst of the worst.
我们就在做这件事。我们正在给这些人送去圣诞节。在监狱里，他们倾向于把囚犯分开并以不同的方式分类。有些人是被单独监禁的。这叫“小黑屋”。他们被认为是最坏中的最坏。
And then on the other side of the spectrum, they have inmates called trustees. And these are inmates who have decided they want to rehabilitate themselves. They may never make parole, but they've decided that they want to be better people now than they were when they walked in. And so they take counseling, they take classes, they get jobs, and they're given more responsibilities. And they don't live in cells, they live in barracks with bunks. And so these are the people we're going to be giving Christmas gifts to.
然后在光谱的另一端，他们有被称为“受托人”的囚犯。这些是决定想要改造自己的囚犯。他们可能永远无法假释，但他们决定现在要成为比刚进来时更好的人。所以他们参加咨询，参加课程，找工作，他们被赋予了更多责任。他们不住牢房，他们住在有双层床的营房里。所以这些人就是我们要送去圣诞礼物的人。
And we go there and we go into the barracks and we start handing these gifts out, and it's amazing watching these guys get these gifts. Their faces just light up. Just the bag itself, the drawings on the bags. You would've assumed that those were drawn specifically for them because they're so proud of these drawings. They are like, "Yo, check it out. This kid drew me a car, and it's red, and that's my favorite color. It's awesome." Another inmate would be like, "Check it out. This kid drew me a house, and then there's a pool. And that's the house I want to live in." Another inmate was like, "Check it out. This kid drew me a horse with a spear sticking out of his head." "That's a unicorn." "It's a spear horse!"
我们去了那里，进入营房，开始分发这些礼物，看着这些人收到礼物真是太棒了。他们的脸亮了起来。单单是袋子本身，袋子上的画。你会以为那些是专门为他们画的，因为他们对这些画如此自豪。他们说，“哟，看看这个。这个孩子给我画了一辆车，是红色的，那是我最喜欢的颜色。太棒了。”另一个囚犯会说，“看看这个。这个孩子给我画了一所房子，还有一个游泳池。那是我想要住的房子。”另一个囚犯说，“看看这个。这个孩子给我画了一匹头上插着长矛的马。”“那是独角兽。”“那是长矛马！”
And to see how happy they were getting these gifts. And for this moment, they're not inmates in a prison anymore. As they're going through these gifts, they're just kids on Christmas. And they're so happy. And they're emptying out the bags and just smoothing out the bags and hanging them on their bunks, and you're watching just the sheer pleasure on their faces as they're going through the gifts. And you're watching that fade away as they find the calendar. "Like seriously, man, what am I supposed to do with this?" Beyond that, they were very appreciative. They were appreciative for the apple, appreciative for the orange, appreciative for the bag. The calendar not so much.
看到他们收到这些礼物有多高兴。在这一刻，他们不再是监狱里的囚犯了。当他们翻看这些礼物时，他们只是圣诞节的孩子。他们太高兴了。他们倒空袋子，把袋子铺平，挂在床铺上，你看着他们翻看礼物时脸上的纯粹快乐。然后你看着当你发现日历时那种快乐消失了。“说真的，伙计，我该拿这个怎么办？”除此之外，他们非常感激。他们感激苹果，感激橘子，感激袋子。日历就没那么感激了。
But we give everybody the gifts, and I notice there's still a lot of gifts left. And so the guard who had been taking us around was like, "You know what? Let's take those and give those to the guys in solitary." Really? Does Santa's naughty list mean nothing at this point? I mean, what happened to be good for goodness' sake? Better not pout, better not cry, better not shout? Santa has problems with those, but murder he's cool with? Really?
但我们把礼物发给了所有人，我注意到还有很多礼物剩下。所以带我们参观的守卫说，“你知道吗？把那些拿去给单独监禁的人吧。”真的吗？圣诞老人的“淘气名单”在这一点上毫无意义吗？我的意思是，那个“好孩子”的初衷发生了什么？“最好别噘嘴，最好别哭，最好别大叫”？圣诞老人对这些有意见，但谋杀他就觉得可以？真的吗？
And we go to solitary. Solitary, each of the doors are these metal doors. And there are these metal doors. And then on the door is a smaller little over door about the size of a shoebox. And that's there. And then there's a guard, and he's got a stick. And he'll take the stick. He takes it to the little shoebox sized oven door and opens up and he's like, "All right, give me a gift." "All right. Do I get a stick?" "No, you'll be fine." "Really? Because you have a stick." "Do it." So I start giving the gifts, and I'm just throwing them in the hole. And we go to the next one, and it's like I'm playing Quidditch, just tossing them in.
我们去了单独监禁区。单独监禁区，每扇门都是这种金属门。有这些金属门。门上有一个小小的、大约鞋盒大小的过门。就是那样。然后有一个守卫，他有一根棍子。他拿着棍子。他把它伸到鞋盒大小的烤箱门那里，打开它，他说，“好吧，给我一个礼物。”“好吧。我能得到一根棍子吗？”“不，你会没事的。”“真的吗？因为你有棍子。”“做吧。”所以我开始分发礼物，我只是把它们扔进洞里。我们去下一个，就像我在玩魁地奇，只是把它扔进去。
And eventually we get to this one, and I throw the gift in, and the guard is about to stick up the door again, and from behind the door I hear this voice and he goes, "Wait. Hold on a second. Hold on. I want to shake his hand." "Well, my friend, I'd love to, but I'm sure the guard has something to say about that." "No, it's fine. Go ahead. Do it." "Really?"
最终我们到了这个，我把礼物扔进去，守卫正准备再次封住门，我从门后听到一个声音，他说，“等等。等等。等等。我想握个手。”“好吧，朋友，我很想，但我肯定守卫对此会有话说。”“不，没关系。去做吧。去做吧。”“真的吗？”
And I'm terrified, because now I can't see anything except eyes back there. And I'm slowly making my way and just thinking, I could shake his hand, and he could eat my fingers. And I'm nervous. And I'm walking closer, and I still can't see anything. And then all of a sudden this hand just comes out. It's a big, meaty hand, because it's a prison hand. And I walk over, and my hand sort of nervously grabs his and shakes it. And he holds on to it and pulls me a little closer.
我吓坏了，因为现在我除了后面的眼睛什么也看不见。我慢慢地走过去，心想，我可以握他的手，他可以把我的手指吃掉。我很紧张。我走得更近了，但我还是什么也看不见。突然一只手伸了出来。那是一只粗壮的手，因为那是监狱的手。我走过去，我的手有点紧张地抓住他的并摇了摇。他抓住我不放，把我拉得更近了一点。
He's like, "Yeah, I thought I knew you. Yeah, I know you." I'm like, "Oh, no you don't. No. No you don't." And he's convinced. He's like, "Yeah, I know you. I know you, man." And now I'm starting to think to myself, Does he know me? He's really convinced. "Yeah, I thought it was you. Yeah, I know you. You're from Austin." Which at that particular moment, I had never felt more pride to be from Dallas. I was just like, "No, I'm from Dallas, [BLEEP]!" At which point, he was like, "Oh, you should really tell people you're from Austin. It's a much nicer place." Thank you, everybody. Thank you.
他说，“是的，我想我认识你。是的，我认识你。”我说，“哦，不，你不认识。不。不，你不认识。”他很确信。他说，“是的，我认识你。我认识你，伙计。”现在我开始心想，他认识我吗？他真的非常确信。“是的，我以为是你。是的，我认识你。你来自奥斯汀。”在那一刻，我从来没有因为来自达拉斯而感到如此自豪。我只是说，“不，我来自达拉斯，[消音]！”此时，他说，“哦，你真的应该告诉别人你来自奥斯汀。那是一个好得多的地方。”谢谢大家。谢谢。
Wyatt Cenac.
怀亚特·塞纳克。
Act Two, Stocking Stuffers.
第二幕，圣诞袜礼品。
Among other things, Edith Zimmerman writes these very short, short stories. Please welcome Edith Zimmerman.
除了其他事情，伊迪丝·齐默尔曼（Edith Zimmerman）还写这些极短的小故事。请欢迎伊迪丝·齐默尔曼。
This story is called "The Holiday Party."
这个故事叫“节日派对”。
"So, do you come here often?" he asked, leaning toward me with a twinkle in his eye and a sprig of mistletoe in his hand. We had been exchanging flirtatious glances across the bar all night. Finally he was making a move. "Yes," I said with a playful smile. "Oh really?" he said. "Yep. I come here every day actually," I said. "On weekdays, they open at 5:00, so I get here 15 minutes before that to wait outside. And then on the weekends they open at 3:00. And then today because it's a holiday party, they opened at noon, and I didn't have to wait outside at all." "Huh," he said, giving me a funny smile. "You really do come here often I guess." "Yep. There's no one else who comes here as much as me. You can ask the manager. They let me keep stuff in the bathroom sometimes." "Ah," he said and looked around the room. "One time I fell down over there and hit my head," I said and pointed to a corner in the bar, "but no one noticed, so I even got to stay here overnight."
“那么，你常来这里吗？”他问道，带着闪烁的眼神和手中拿着的一小枝槲寄生向我倾斜。我们整晚都在吧台对面交换挑逗的目光。最后他采取了行动。“是的，”我带着顽皮的微笑说。“哦真的吗？”他说。“是的。事实上我每天都来，”我说。“工作日，他们5点开门，所以我提前15分钟到那里在外面等。周末他们3点开门。今天因为是节日派对，他们中午就开门了，我根本不用在外面等。”“嗯，”他说，给了我一个有趣的微笑。“我猜你确实常来这里。”“是的。没有其他人像我来得这么频繁。你可以问经理。他们有时让我把东西放在洗手间里。”“啊，”他说，环顾房间。“有一次我摔倒在那里撞到了头，”我说，指着吧台的一个角落，“但没人注意到，所以我甚至得以在这里过夜。”
This one is called "Christmas Cookies."
这个叫“圣诞饼干”。
"Good morning!" I said to my students. "Does anyone like--" And here, I reached under my desk to produce a heaping tray of homemade treats. "--Christmas cookies? Yes!" they screamed. "How much?" I asked. "A lot!" they screamed. "Do you love them?" I asked. "Yes!" they screamed. "We love them!" "So why don't you marry them?" I asked. "No!" they screamed. "Why not?" I asked. "You can't marry cookies!" they screamed. I looked down at my engagement ring and slid my hand behind my back so the children couldn't see. "Is that like for sure a fact or is it something you just assume?" I asked.
“早上好！”我对我的学生们说。“有谁喜欢……”在这儿，我伸手从桌子底下拿出一大盘自制的点心。“……圣诞饼干吗？有！”他们尖叫道。“多少？”我问。“很多！”他们尖叫道。“你们喜欢它们吗？”我问。“是的！”他们尖叫道。“我们爱它们！”“那你们为什么不嫁给它们？”我问。“不！”他们尖叫道。“为什么不？”我问。“你不能嫁给饼干！”他们尖叫道。我低头看了看我的订婚戒指，把手移到背后，这样孩子们就看不见了。“那是肯定的事实，还是你们只是假设？”我问。
Edith Zimmerman. She's the editor at TheHairpin.com where she writes all day, every day.
伊迪丝·齐默尔曼。她是TheHairpin.com的编辑，在那里她整天，每天都在写作。
Coming up, more Comedians of Christmas. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，更多的“圣诞喜剧演员”。一分钟后继续我们的节目，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show of course we choose a theme, bringing a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show for Christmas, a comedy Christmas special. We wanted something funny for the holidays, so we invited comedians and other performers to go on stage at various locations wherever they perform. And we created two shows at a club in Brooklyn called Littlefield to record them in front of live audiences. In our search for holiday jokes, Christmas jokes, holiday humor of all kinds, one of the kids of one of our producers found this book called Christmas Crackups and knew that we were doing the show and sent it into the office very generously. Though I'm supposed to return it when I'm done. I thought I would read you a few of the jokes.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们当然会选择一个主题，围绕该主题带来各种各样的故事。今天的圣诞节目，一个喜剧圣诞特别节目。我们想要一些关于假期的有趣的东西，所以我们邀请了喜剧演员和其他表演者到他们表演的各个地点登台。我们在布鲁克林一个叫Littlefield的俱乐部里制作了两个节目，并在现场观众面前录制它们。在我们寻找节日笑话、圣诞笑话、各种节日幽默的过程中，我们的一位制片人的孩子找到了这本叫《圣诞笑话》的书，知道我们在做这个节目，非常慷慨地把它寄到了办公室。虽然我用完后还得把它还回去。我想给你们读几个笑话。
What kind of bills to elves have to pay? Jingle bills. What nationality are Santa and Mrs. Claus? North Polish. Suddenly I feel like Steven Wright or something. I'm deadpan. On which side of Santa's face is his beard? The outside.
精灵们必须付什么样的账单？叮当账单（Jingle bills）。圣诞老人和克劳斯夫人是什么国籍？北波兰人（North Polish）。突然我觉得自己像斯蒂芬·赖特（Steven Wright）什么的。我面无表情。圣诞老人的胡子在他脸的哪一边？外面。
I want to play you guys one more clip that Jonathan Menjivar got when he was out on the schoolyard at PS 11 talking to kids about Christmas jokes. He talked to this one kid and he said, "Have you got any Christmas jokes?" And the kid says--
我想给你们再放一段剪辑，是乔纳森·门吉瓦尔在PS 11小学的操场上和孩子们谈论圣诞笑话时录到的。他和这个孩子谈话，他说，“你有圣诞笑话吗？”孩子说——
I don't want to do that if it's going on radio.
如果这是在广播，我不想这么做。
Yeah, don't worry about it. No one's going to know who you are.
是的，别担心。没人会知道你是谁。
Oh, OK!
哦，好的！
OK, so now the kid knows that the kid is anonymous, so here's the joke that this kid tells.
好的，现在孩子知道他是匿名的，所以这是这个孩子讲的笑话。
Knock, knock.
敲敲。
Who's there?
谁在那里？
Ella.
艾拉（Ella）。
Ella who?
艾拉谁？
Ella really got to go poo.
艾拉（I’ll a）真的得去拉屎了。
The kid works blue. The kid knows, I'm anonymous. Great. I've got this dirty material that I've got to try out on public broadcasting.
这个孩子讲黄段子。孩子知道，我是匿名的。太棒了。我有这些肮脏的材料，我得在公共广播里试一下。
Act Three, Little Altar Boy.
第三幕，小祭坛男孩。
Despite our nation's best efforts to turn Christmas into a festival that's about gifts and toys and buying stuff, it is still a religious holiday. Please welcome comedian Mike Birbiglia.
尽管我们国家尽最大努力把圣诞节变成一个关于礼物、玩具和买东西的节日，但它仍然是一个宗教节日。请欢迎喜剧演员迈克·比比利亚。
One of the reasons Christmas was a really big deal to me when I was a kid was that I was really good at being Catholic. And not everyone was. My brother Joe only came to church on Christmas and even then he'd show up late. He'd be like, "Mike, the later you show up, the shorter it is." And then he'd change the lyrics to the hymns. There was this one we used to sing every week that goes, "Christ has died. Christ is risen. Christ will come again." And Joe's lyrics were, "Christ has lied. Christ is in prison. Christ will come at 10:00." I'd try so hard not to laugh, because I was on Jesus's team.
圣诞节对我小时候来说之所以是一件大事，原因之一是我很擅长做天主教徒。并不是每个人都这样。我弟弟乔（Joe）只在圣诞节来教堂，即使那样他也会迟到。他会说，“迈克，你来得越晚，它就越短。”然后他会改写赞美诗的歌词。我们过去每周都会唱一首，“基督已死。基督已复活。基督必将来临。”乔的歌词是，“基督撒谎了。基督在监狱里。基督将在10点来。”我会努力不笑，因为我是耶稣团队的。
Well I went to church every week with my mom and I thought it made me her favorite. My mom decided early on that I would be a priest. And I really thought that I would, and I liked the idea. So every week we'd go to church. When other kids would go to the park or the mall, we'd go to church. And sometimes I'd be like, "Hey, Mom, I want to go to the mall." And my mom would say, "Like fun are you going to the mall." That's an expression that my mom uses. Like fun. Which is her way of saying, Like Hell, because she's Catholic. And for Catholics, Hell is fun.
嗯，我每周都和我妈去教堂，我觉得这让我成了她最喜欢的孩子。我妈很早就决定我会成为一名牧师。我确实想过我会成为牧师，我也喜欢这个想法。所以每周我们都会去教堂。当其他孩子去公园或商场时，我们去教堂。有时我会说，“嘿，妈，我想去商场。”我妈会说，“你就像去商场一样去玩吧。”那是我妈用的一种表达方式。就像玩。这是她说“该死”的方式，因为她是天主教徒。对于天主教徒来说，地狱才是好玩的。
When you're seven, and your mom sends you to Catholic school, it's all pretty simple. They're like, "There's this guy Jesus, and he totally loves you." And you're like, "Great." And they're like, "You love him too, right?" And you're like, "I'm sorry. Do I know this guy?" And they're like, "You know, from the cross. That guy loves you, and you love him." And it starts innocently enough, as innocently as man/boy love can start. You just kind of accept it. "There's this guy, Jesus, who everybody's afraid of but everybody loves because he loves everybody. And a long time ago, some people killed him, and it's not totally your fault. So don't be scared or sad, because he's living forever next to God who's his dad, even though he's also God. And also there's this whole Holy Spirit part too that no one really understands. Am I going too fast for you, seven-year-old boy?"
当你七岁时，你妈送你去天主教学校，一切都很简单。他们说，“有这个叫耶稣的家伙，他完全爱你。”你说，“太棒了。”他们说，“你也爱他，对吧？”你说，“抱歉。我认识这个家伙吗？”他们说，“你知道的，从十字架上。那个家伙爱你，你也爱他。”这开始得足够天真，像人/男孩之爱能开始的那样天真。你只是接受了它。“有这个叫耶稣的家伙，每个人都怕他，但每个人都爱他，因为他爱每个人。很久以前，有些人杀了他，这不完全是你的错。所以不要害怕或难过，因为他正住在上帝旁边，上帝是他爸爸，尽管他也是上帝。而且还有这整个圣灵的部分，没人真正理解。我刚才说得太快了吗，七岁的小男孩？”
So you go with that for a few years. And then you're 11 and you get the word that Father Grady wants you to be one of his new altar boys. He's seen your work at recess on the kickball field, and he thinks you've got what it takes to snuff out candles and hold a chalice and not trip and fall on your robe. So I became an altar boy. And the answer's no. I wasn't, and I think it's because they knew I was a talker. I have that look about me.
所以你接受那个几年。然后你11岁了，你听到消息说格雷迪神父希望你成为他的新祭坛男孩。他看到了你在踢球场上课间休息时的表现，他认为你有能力熄灭蜡烛、拿着圣餐杯，而不会绊倒在长袍上。所以我成了祭坛男孩。答案是不。我不是，我想这是因为他们知道我是个话痨。我有那种外表。
And I loved being an altar boy because church was glamorous. The priests have these multicolor robes. As an altar boy, even you have a robe, just a plain white one. It's like karate where they start you with the white belt and then you get the different color belts once you start kicking some Devil ass. So I loved being an altar boy, especially on Christmas. That's when I could really show off, because Christmas was cool. I mean everyone came to Christmas Mass. People who you never saw at church came to Christmas mass, people like my brother Joe.
我喜欢做祭坛男孩，因为教堂很迷人。牧师有这些多色长袍。作为祭坛男孩，即使你也有长袍，只是纯白色的。就像空手道，他们让你从白带开始，然后当你开始踢恶魔屁股时，你会得到不同颜色的腰带。所以我喜欢做祭坛男孩，特别是在圣诞节。那是当我可以真正炫耀的时候，因为圣诞节很酷。我的意思是每个人都来参加圣诞弥撒。你从未在教堂见过的人都来参加圣诞弥撒，比如我弟弟乔。
And they'd see me there with their families and they'd see me in my robe, all fitting in around the church. I acted like I owned the place. I'd go, "Oh yeah? You want to walk up on the altar? That's probably not a great idea. That's where J-Dog hangs out." "You know Jesus too? Yeah, he's a pretty good friend of mine. It's cool of you to come by, but seriously where were you during Advent?" That's for the real diehard Catholics, that last one.
他们会看到我在那里和他们的家人在一起，他们会看到我穿着长袍，在教堂周围合群。我表现得好像我拥有这个地方一样。我会说，“哦是吗？你想走到祭坛上？那可能不是个好主意。那是J-Dog（耶稣）待的地方。”“你也认识耶稣吗？是的，他是我的好朋友。你来这里很酷，但说真的，你在将临期去哪了？”那是给真正的死忠天主教徒的，最后一句。
Shortly after I finished college, my mom developed this condition where as far as the doctors could tell, part of her spine was pushing into her spinal cord. And they weren't sure what was happening, but she was experiencing chronic pain all over her body. And so the doctors did this operation, and the problem is the pain didn't go away. So my mom was faced with both the original pain and then the pain of this operation. And she was laid up for months. She was in bed. And so I came home and lived with them to administer her pain meds, and get her meals.
我大学毕业后不久，我妈患上了这种病，据医生所知，她脊椎的一部分压迫到了她的脊髓。他们不确定发生了什么，但她全身都在经历慢性疼痛。所以医生做了这个手术，问题是疼痛没有消失。所以我妈既面临着最初的疼痛，又面临着手术的疼痛。她躺了好几个月。她卧床不起。所以我回家和他们住在一起，给她吃止痛药，给她做饭。
She was also prescribed this drug called Ativan, which is an anti-anxiety. And she was supposed to take it three times a day, but pretty soon she wanted to take it five or six times a day. And I wasn't sure why. And I asked her, and she pulled me aside and she said, "I'm dying." And I was so upset that I called her doctor and I asked him if my mom was dying. And he said, "Well we don't know what's happening exactly, but there's no reason to believe she's dying. Just make sure she doesn't take too much Ativan. It's making her delirious."
她还被开了这种叫阿提凡（Ativan）的药，是一种抗焦虑药。她本应该一天吃三次，但很快她想一天吃五六次。我不确定为什么。我问她，她把我拉到一边说，“我要死了。”我太难过了，我打电话给她医生，问他我妈是不是快死了。他说，“嗯，我们不知道确切发生了什么，但没有理由相信她快死了。确保她不要吃太多阿提凡。这让她产生了谵妄。”
So I hid the Ativan. And it drove my mother crazy. At one point she shouted, "Michael, where is the Ativan?" And I said, "Mom, I can't give you the Ativan." And she said, "I am your mother and if I say get me the Ativan, you get me the Ativan." And I said, "Mom, like fun am I getting you the Ativan."
所以我藏起了阿提凡。这让我母亲快疯了。有一次她大喊，“迈克尔，阿提凡在哪里？”我说，“妈，我不能给你阿提凡。”她说，“我是你妈，如果我说给我阿提凡，你就得给我阿提凡。”我说，“妈，我绝不可能给你阿提凡。”
She started pulling me aside every day and she'd say, "Michael, I'm dying and I'm going to Hell." And the way she said it wasn't in that exaggerated way that people use it, where they say, I'm going to Hell. She said it as though it was the next stop on her train, like it was this actual location. It wasn't a concept. It was like, I'm going to Hell on Tuesday. And I'd say, "Mom, you're not going to Hell." And she said, "No, there's things that I've done in my life that you don't know about." And I'd say "Mom, if you're going to Hell, Hell is going to be really crowded, because I had you as a first-round draft pick for Heaven."
她开始每天把我拉到一边，说，“迈克尔，我要死了，我要下地狱了。”她说这话的方式不像人们夸张地说“我要下地狱了”那样。她说的好像那是她火车的下一站，就像那是一个实际的位置。这不是一个概念。就像，“我星期二要下地狱了。”我说，“妈，你不会下地狱的。”她说，“不，我一生中做过一些你不知道的事情。”我说，“妈，如果你要下地狱，地狱会非常拥挤，因为我把你作为上天堂的第一轮选秀首选。”
And she wouldn't laugh. I mean there wasn't a lot of laughing in this period. And eventually my mom got better. But the whole thing shook me up. It was this side of Catholicism I never thought about as a kid. And I never went back to church. I can't be part of an organization that convinced my mom she was headed for eternal torture. Like Hell am I going to a church like that, except of course on Christmas.
她没有笑。我的意思是这段时间没多少笑声。最终我妈好转了。但整件事让我感到震惊。这是我小时候从未想过的天主教的一面。我再也没回过教堂。我不能成为一个让我想起我妈正走向永恒折磨的组织的一部分。我绝不会去那样的教堂，当然圣诞节除外。
Mike Birbiglia. He's the author of a book based on his one-man show called Sleepwalk With Me: and Other Painfully True Stories.
迈克·比比利亚。他是基于他个人秀的同名书《与我梦游：以及其他痛苦的真实故事》的作者。
Act Four, One Lord A-Leaping.
第四幕，一个领主跳跃。
Gabe Liedman and Jenny Slate perform together all kinds of places. They have a video series called Bestie x Bestie . They have their own weekly show, Big Terrific in Williamsburg, Brooklyn. Please welcome Gabe Liedman and Jenny Slate.
盖布·里德曼（Gabe Liedman）和珍妮·斯莱特（Jenny Slate）在各种地方一起表演。他们有一个视频系列叫《闺蜜 x 闺蜜》。他们在布鲁克林威廉斯堡有自己的每周节目《Big Terrific》。请欢迎盖布·里德曼和珍妮·斯莱特。
Hi. My name is Jenny.
嗨。我叫珍妮。
I'm Gabe. We're thrilled to be here.
我是盖布。我们很高兴来到这里。
Yeah. We're really excited and we put on our holiday best.
是的。我们真的很兴奋，我们穿上了我们最好的节日服装。
Yeah, you look great.
是的，你看上去棒极了。
Thank you very much.
非常感谢。
You look really good.
你看上去真的很好。
Well, I think I sort of look like--
嗯，我想我看起来有点……
You look like Stevie Nicks.
你看上去像史蒂薇·妮克丝（Stevie Nicks）。
Oh, thank you.
哦，谢谢。
Yes. That's the highest compliment.
是的。那是最高的赞美。
It is the highest compliment you can give a woman. I don't want to ruin the vibe or anything, but I'd just like to say how happy I am to have a boyfriend that I can also perform with--
这是你可以给女性的最高赞美。我不想破坏这种氛围或者其他什么，但我只想说，我很高兴有一个我也可以一起表演的男朋友……
A what?
什么？
--over the holidays--
……在假期里……
A what?
什么？
--because it's really like a double [INTERPOSING VOICES].
……因为这真的很像双重的[交叉声音]。
She's kidding. Yeah, we're not a couple.
她在开玩笑。是的，我们不是一对。
Its really nice to have a boyfriend.
有一个男朋友真好。
You guys probably already know that without being told, because you can hear my voice.
你们可能不用说就已经知道了，因为你们能听到我的声音。
And to be in a couple is very important to me.
而且能成为一对对我来说非常重要。
We're just friends and comedy partners and we spend all the time together in the world.
我们只是朋友和喜剧搭档，我们花了一切世界上的时间在一起。
I'm a very loving person.
我是一个非常有爱心的人。
But we're just friends and we work together.
但我们只是朋友，我们一起工作。
It's sort of my main quality that I'm very loving.
我非常有爱心这算是我主要的品质。
Obviously. No duh times a million. And I can tell she's pretty.
显然。当然了。而且我知道她很漂亮。
I'm happy about it.
我对此很高兴。
I'm not blind. I'm not a blind comedian.
我不是瞎子。我不是盲人喜剧演员。
But it is lovely to be in love because--
但恋爱真是太好了，因为……
Yeah, or in whatever. Just hanging out in Brooklyn.
是的，或者不管什么。只是在布鲁克林闲逛。
I'm very, very grateful. I'm just in general in sort of a sappy mood I guess, because I really, really love the holidays.
我非常非常感激。我只是总体上处于一种多愁善感的情绪中，我想，因为我真的，真的很喜欢假期。
Me too.
我也是。
I get super into it.
我超级投入其中。
Or I love other people's holidays. I wish I had Christmas.
或者我喜欢其他人的假期。我希望我有圣诞节。
Yeah. We should just get real about it.
是的。我们应该直说吧。
Yeah, we're Jewish. Yeah.
是的，我们是犹太人。是的。
But I love Hanukkah. I love it.
但我喜欢光明节。我爱它。
You do?
你喜欢吗？
Yeah. My family just floored it, and I can remember almost all of my presents that I got. They were so shocking and awesome, I can remember each one.
是的。我的家人只是全力以赴，我几乎能记住我得到的所有礼物。它们太令人震惊和棒了，我能记住每一个。
You're so lucky. I don't know what this says about me. I mean I know my parents were the sweetest people ever. They were such good parents, but all I can remember is my worst Hanukkah present.
你真幸运。我不知道这说明了我什么。我的意思是，我知道我父母是有史以来最甜蜜的人。他们是很好的父母，但我只能记住我最糟糕的光明节礼物。
What was it?
是什么？
I have two siblings. And one night for Hanukkah we all opened our presents and we had all gotten thermometers.
我有两个兄弟姐妹。有天晚上为了光明节，我们都打开了我们的礼物，我们都得到了温度计。
No! That's horrible!
不！那太可怕了！
All three of us, three thermometers.
我们三个，三个温度计。
That's medical!
那是医疗用品！
No, not for taking a fever. It was for the temperature outside.
不，不是为了量体温。那是为了外面的温度。
No, that's even worse!
不，那更糟！
It's way worse.
那是更糟。
I don't even get that. Why don't you just use your face? How does it feel on your face?
我甚至不懂那个。为什么你不直接用你的脸呢？感觉在你的脸上怎么样？
Yeah, totally.
是的，完全同意。
Why did you each need one?
为什么你们每个人都需要一个？
I don't know.
我不知道。
You only need one, right?
你只需要一个，对吧？
Yeah. You don't need any!
是的。你根本不需要任何一个！
Right. You don't need any.
对。你一个都不需要。
We had AOL. It was fine. It was fine. Everyone knew what the weather was.
我们有AOL。没关系。没关系。每个人都知道天气是多少。
I really love your parents.
我真的很喜欢你的父母。
They're the best.
他们是最好的。
I mean, hopefully my in-laws one day.
我的意思是，希望将来是我公婆。
That would be weird.
那会很奇怪。
But that is a horrible present and it's stupid and I don't like it.
但那是一个可怕的礼物，而且很愚蠢，我不喜欢它。
Yeah.
是的。
But what I want to talk more about is how good one of my presents was one time. I think that I'll never die because of the energy that I got from that one day of getting the present. It gave me an extra heart somewhere in my body. That's how exciting it was. OK. It was from my grandparents, who were a wild card, a lot of mock turtlenecks in the mix for sure.
但我更想谈谈有一次我的一个礼物有多好。我想我永远不会死，因为我从那天得到礼物中获得的能量。它在我的身体某处给了我一颗额外的心脏。它就是这么令人兴奋。好的。它来自我的祖父母，他们是通配符，肯定有很多高领毛衣在里面。
Yes definitely.
是的，绝对。
But I opened it up, and it was a digital clock radio-- Hold on. I know. --with a tape deck in it.
但我打开它，这是一个数字时钟收音机——等一下。我知道。——里面有一个磁带卡座。
Nice.
不错。
OK?
好吗？
Nice.
不错。
And then my older sister to top it off gave me a cassingle--
然后我的大姐姐为了锦上添花给了我一个单曲磁带……
Yes, of course.
是的，当然。
Gabe taught me that word. --of "From a Distance" by Bette Middler, which I know how to sign.
盖布教了我那个词。——贝特·米德勒（Bette Middler）的“从远处”（From a Distance），我知道怎么签名。
Yes.
是的。
Thank you. I know. And I woke up every morning to "From a Distance" and I felt mature. I felt beautiful. I felt ready for my day.
谢谢。我知道。而且我每天早上都在“从远处”中醒来，我感觉成熟。我感觉美丽。我感觉为我的一天做好了准备。
Yes, that is a good present.
是的，那是一个好礼物。
Well I didn't ask for any presents this year, because I have everything that I need. And I would like to say that the best gift that I could have ever received is to have a wonderful boyfriend like Gabe Liedman.
嗯，我今年没要任何礼物，因为我拥有我需要的一切。我想说的是，我能收到的最好的礼物就是拥有一个像盖布·里德曼这样出色的男朋友。
Or whatever that you have.
或者你有的任何什么。
That's right. So, Season's Greetings.
没错。所以，节日问候。
Season's Greetings, guys.
节日问候，伙计们。
Let's find some mistletoe!
我们去找点槲寄生吧！
Yeah, and take it down so no one gets hurt! It's poisonous.
是的，把它取下来，这样就不会有人受伤了！它有毒。
Happy Holidays! Thank you.
节日快乐！谢谢。
Goodnight.
晚安。
Jenny Slate wrote and voiced the award-winning film Marcel the Shell with Shoes On , and can be seen on HBO's Bored to Death . Gabe Liedman writes for videogum.com, and can be seen on AOL.com's new series, The One.
珍妮·斯莱特编剧并配音了获奖影片《穿着鞋子的贝壳玛塞尔》，可以在HBO的《凡人烦恼》中看到。盖布·里德曼为videogum.com写稿，可以在AOL.com的新系列《唯一》中看到。
Act Five, 'Twas the Fight Before Christmas.
第五幕，“圣诞前的战斗”。
So we booked a bunch of comedians to do stories about Christmas. And for reasons I don't even understand or care to speculate about just a number of them ended up doing stories that heavily involved their moms. Go figure. Please welcome our next comedian, Julian McCullough.
所以我们预订了一堆喜剧演员来做关于圣诞节的故事。由于一些我甚至不理解或不想猜测的原因，他们中的不少人最终做了严重涉及他们母亲的故事。想一想。请欢迎我们的下一位喜剧演员，朱利安·麦卡洛（Julian McCullough）。
When I was a 14 years old, I lived with my dad and my mom in southern New Jersey. And one Sunday, my mom was like, "Hey, let's go out to your favorite restaurant for breakfast." And I was like, "Why? OK." So we go to breakfast and after we leave we're driving home, and she stops. The car has to stop at a railroad crossing. And she turns to me and she says, "How would you feel if I moved to Tennessee?" And I kind of understood the finality of what she was saying, even though she didn't use the word divorce or anything like that. And it's amazing how fast defense mechanisms can kick in, because I remember immediately my reaction was, "Oh my God. Go. When was the last time Patricia did something for Patricia?"
当我14岁时，我和我的父亲和母亲住在新泽西州南部。一个周日，我妈说，“嘿，我们去你最喜欢的餐厅吃早餐吧。”我说，“为什么？好吧。”所以我们去吃早餐，离开后我们在开车回家，她停了下来。车必须在一个铁路道口停下。她转过身对我说，“如果我搬到田纳西州，你会怎么想？”我有点理解她所说的话的最终性，尽管她没有用离婚这个词或者类似的词。令人惊奇的是防御机制能激发得有多快，因为我记得我的直接反应是，“哦，天哪。去吧。帕特里夏（Patricia）上次为帕特里夏做点什么是什么时候？”
So another thing you should know is that this didn't seem that strange to me, because my parents had moved us so many times. I was born in Philadelphia. We had lived in Portland, Oakland, San Francisco, Pittsfield, Massachusetts, and southern New Jersey. People always asked if I was an Army brat, and it wasn't true at all. My parents would just get bored and move us. So I was used to an unstable existence. I was new in school almost every year. And I just thought this seemed kind of logical for my mom to all of a sudden move to Tennessee for no reason.
你应该知道的另一件事是，这对我来说看起来并不奇怪，因为我的父母搬家搬了太多次了。我出生在费城。我们住过波特兰、奥克兰、旧金山、马萨诸塞州皮茨菲尔德和新泽西州南部。人们总是问我是不是军人家属，根本不是。我父母只是会感到无聊，然后就搬走。所以我习惯了不稳定的存在。我几乎每年在学校都是新生。我只是觉得我妈突然搬到田纳西州去没有任何理由似乎很合乎逻辑。
So that started a series of visits to my mom down in Tennessee for the next five years. I would go in the summers when I didn't have school. And I really started to dread it. By the second time that I went to visit her, my mom's new boyfriend, Rick, showed up at the airport to pick me up. And Rick showed up on a Harley, which is a motorcycle, to pick someone up at an airport. And I was like, "That's awesome. I'll just leave my bags on the twirly thing until I go back to New Jersey." He was wearing a T-shirt that's very popular. It's a Harley Davidson T-shirt, and the back of it said, "If you can read this, the bitch fell off." And I was like, "That's my mom. Is she OK? Let's get her."
所以这开始了接下来的五年里我到田纳西州看望我母亲的一系列探访。我会在我没有学校的夏天去。我真的开始害怕了。第二次去探望她时，我母亲的新男友里克（Rick）出现在机场接我。里克出现在哈雷摩托车上，这是一种摩托车，去机场接人。我说，“太棒了。我就把我的包留在转盘上直到我回新泽西州。”他穿了一件很受欢迎的T恤。那是一件哈雷戴维森T恤，背部写着，“如果你能读懂这个，那个婊子掉下来了。”我说，“那是我的母亲。她没事吧？让我们去救她。”
To give you an idea of what Rick looked like, he was about 5'7". He had been a commercial roofer for many years. He had started out in a biker gang, and I guess decided to move on from that life and became a commercial roofer. So he was very, very strong and muscly and very red. He was red everywhere from the sun and from just anger.
给你一个关于里克长相的概念，他大约5英尺7英寸。他做了很多年商业屋顶工。他开始在摩托车帮里，我想他决定从那种生活中走出来，成为了一名商业屋顶工。所以他非常、非常强壮，肌肉发达，而且非常红。他全身都是红色的，来自阳光，也来自愤怒。
And the tension between me and Rick started immediately and built from there. See, I thought Rick was an anti-intellectual, homophobic, racist, gun-toting alcoholic. And Rick thought that I was a wimpy, arrogant, self-entitled kid whose grandparents were putting him through college. And we were both dead on.
我和里克之间的紧张关系立即开始了，并从那里开始建立。你看，我认为里克是一个反智、恐同、种族主义、携带枪支的酒鬼。而里克认为我是一个懦弱、傲慢、自我感觉良好的孩子，他的祖父母让他上大学。我们俩都完全正确。
So finally after five years of going down there in the summers, my mom convinces me and my sister to visit her for Christmas for the first time. She had always been begging, "Hey, maybe for Christmas one year you should come down." And I didn't want to do that for a couple reasons. One, you just heard everything. Two, I had a sweet Christmas going on with my dad's parents. My grandparents in Philadelphia threw the most amazing Christmas. They threw a Thomas Kinkade painting Christmas.
所以终于在夏天去那里五年后，我母亲说服我和我妹妹第一次在圣诞节去探望她。她一直都在恳求，“嘿，也许有一年圣诞节你们应该下来。”我不想那样做，原因有几个。一，你刚听到了所有事情。二，我父亲的父母那边过着很棒的圣诞节。我在费城的祖父母举办了最精彩的圣诞节。他们举办了一个像托马斯·金凯德（Thomas Kinkade）画作一样的圣诞节。
But finally me and my sister-- she lived in San Francisco at the time, she was older --decided we would do that for my mom. And we go to Christmas. Now Rick was on his best behavior. In fact, he had a smile plastered on his face that my mom had clearly put there for him. But it's going fine. He's behaving himself, and so are we.
但最终我和我妹妹——她当时住在旧金山，她年龄较大——决定我们应该为我母亲做那个。我们去过圣诞节。现在里克表现得最好。事实上，他脸上挂着我母亲显然为他放上去的微笑。但一切顺利。他表现得很好，我们也一样。
And we have dinner that night, and my mom cooked a great dinner. One other thing is that my mom was a vegetarian my entire life. And she also was a poet, and she read all the time, and she meditated. She did all these things until she got to Tennessee and she threw all of that out the window, because it made them uncomfortable. So she started eating meat and cooking ribs and wings and shepherds pie. And that's what we had for dinner. She also got tattoos at 47. She got a black widow spider on her hand.
那天晚上我们吃晚饭，我母亲做了一顿丰盛的晚餐。另一件事是我母亲我一生中都是素食主义者。她也是一位诗人，她总是阅读，而且她冥想。她做了所有这些事情，直到她到达田纳西州，她把所有这些都抛到了窗外，因为那让他们感到不舒服。所以她开始吃肉，做排骨、翅膀和牧羊人派。这就是我们晚餐吃的。她还在47岁时纹了纹身。她在手上纹了一只黑寡妇蜘蛛。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
That's the laugh of a man who that's not his mom. She also had a tattoo of an apple with a bite taken out of it on her upper thigh, which I didn't need to see to believe.
那是那个不是他母亲的男人的笑声。她在大腿上还有一个被咬了一口的苹果纹身，我不需要看就知道是真的。
And by the way, I have to give them credit. They did a great job on the house. It was decorated, lit with Christmas lights everywhere. The tree was big and decorated. And there were presents. And we were sitting down to this dinner, and my mom was obviously really excited to have us there. She was so happy, she was choking back tears.
顺便说一下，我必须给他们打分。他们在房子里做得很棒。它经过装饰，到处都点亮了圣诞灯。树很大，装饰得很漂亮。还有礼物。我们坐下来吃这顿饭，我母亲显然很高兴我们能在那里。她太高兴了，她噎住了眼泪。
And Rick was drinking tequila out of a bottle to celebrate the fact that he had tequila, a whole bottle. So he was drinking Patron Silver, which if you don't know is a very unique bottle. It's a very thick, square, heavy bottle. So he's drinking that. He finishes the entire bottle of Patron Silver at dinner. And like a human, passes out.
里克在喝瓶子里的龙舌兰酒，庆祝他有龙舌兰酒，一整瓶。所以他喝的是Patron Silver，如果你不知道，那是一个非常独特的瓶子。这是一个非常厚、正方形、沉重的瓶子。所以他在喝那个。他在晚餐时喝完了整瓶Patron Silver。像人类一样，晕过去了。
So he goes to lay down, and now it's just me and my mom and my sister. And it's beautiful. And we're having Christmas. And it's the tree and the fireplace and the music. And we're just catching up. And I'm making my mom and my sister laugh with stories about college. And it's going really nicely.
所以他去躺下，现在只有我和我妈还有我妹妹。这很美。我们正在过圣诞节。有树、壁炉和音乐。我们只是在叙旧。我讲着关于大学的故事，让我妈和我妹妹笑。一切都进行得很好。
And then the subject comes up-- I think my mom brought it up --of Rick's pride and how it's always an issue, the Southern/ Northern thing. And I said, "You know, it's just so weird for us to understand why he cares so much about that, because you know what the North thinks about the South?" And she said, "What?" And I said, "We don't. We pretty much won and we're like, bye!" Which I was very proud of at the time. I thought that was very witty. Somebody who didn't like it was Rick, who apparently had been awake enough to hear me say that.
然后话题提出来了——我想是我妈提出来的——关于里克的自尊心，以及南方/北方的问题为什么总是一个问题。我说，“你知道，我们要理解他为什么那么在乎这一点真的很奇怪，因为你知道北方对南方怎么看吗？”她说，“怎么看？”我说，“我们不看。我们基本上赢了，我们就像，拜拜！”当时我对此感到非常自豪。我觉得那很机智。不喜欢它的人是里克，显然他醒着，听到了我说的话。
[BOTTLE ROLLING ON THE FLOOR]
（瓶子在地板上滚动）
And that was him getting off of the bed. I've been doing comedy for nine years. That's the first time a bottle rolling on the floor was perfect for the story. "Uh-oh. He's awake! It's a Christmas miracle."
那就是他从床上起来。我做喜剧九年了。这是第一次瓶子在地板上滚动对这个故事来说是完美的。“呃哦。他醒了！这是个圣诞奇迹。”
All of a sudden, Rick comes out of his bedroom like a bull in a rodeo. He charges across the room with just jeans on and no shirt. So he's got all his prison tats showing. He's bright red. His eyes are just as red as his skin. And I don't know if any of you have ever dealt with someone that was so drunk that they weren't there, but Rick wasn't there. And I've been struggling with how to describe what he was saying for a show like this. So let's just say I'll say what he said, and you guys can put in the F word every other word. Fair enough? He came out of the room straight at me first saying, "Get out of my house." And then to my sister, "You get out of my house." Are we doing the F thing? OK.
突然，里克像罗迪欧里的公牛一样从卧室里出来。他冲过房间，只穿着牛仔裤，没穿上衣。所以他所有的监狱纹身都露了出来。他红得发亮。他的眼睛和他的皮肤一样红。我不知道你们中是否有人曾经和喝得烂醉以至于不在状态的人打交道，但里克不在状态。我一直在努力描述他在像这样的节目里说的话。所以让我们说，我说出他说的话，你们可以每隔一个词加入那个F词。公平吗？他从房间里出来，直接冲向我，先说，“滚出我的房子。”然后对我妹妹，“你滚出我的房子。”我们在做那个F词吗？好的。
My mom said, "Rick, please calm down and go back to bed." And I say, "Yeah." And he said-- you can add in a couple of B's and C's on this one too. He said, "I don't want these spoiled Yanks in my house. Nobody comes into my house in my country and tells me that I'm not good enough." So my mom says, "Rick, you're drunk and you're being stupid."
我妈说，“里克，请冷静下来，回床上睡觉。”我说，“是的。”他说——你也可以在这个上面加几个B词和C词。他说，“我不想要这些被宠坏的北方佬在我的房子里。没有人能进入我的房子、我的国家，告诉我不够好。”所以我妈说，“里克，你喝醉了，你很愚蠢。”
And that's when he turned, grabbed the bottle of Patron Silver that was empty, and threw it at my mom as hard as he could. It hit her in the chest and made a sickening smack sound. And her chest immediately started to turned black. My mom bruises easily, but that's not fair either way. So my mom said to Rick, "You promised you wouldn't do this on Christmas." And that's when me and my sister realized that this was the kind of thing that was going on a lot.
就在那时他转身，抓起那瓶空了的Patron Silver，尽可能用力地朝我妈扔去。它打在她的胸口，发出令人作呕的啪的一声。她的胸口立刻开始变黑。我妈很容易擦伤，但这无论如何都不公平。所以我妈对里克说，“你答应过你不会在圣诞节这样做的。”就在那时，我和我妹妹意识到这就是经常发生的那种事情。
So then he turns to me and he says, "I will kill you tonight." And people say that a lot I think and don't mean it, but that's not what he was doing. So now me and my sister decide to cower behind the Christmas tree, which is a weird place for a Christmas tree to be. They're not used to breaking up fights. In fact, the tree was so scared, I think it unplugged itself so that Rick wouldn't notice it.
然后他转向我，说，“我今晚杀了你。”人们经常那样说，我想，但并不是认真的，但那不是他正在做的。所以现在我和我妹妹决定躲在圣诞树后面，这是一个圣诞树待的奇怪地方。它们不习惯打架。事实上，那棵树太害怕了，我想它把自己拔掉了，这样里克就不会注意到它。
So now my mom decides that I guess we could leave. So we leave. We get in the car, and Rick is chasing us out to the driveway. And we get in a car and just start driving at 1:00AM on Christmas Eve in our pajamas with nowhere to go. We eventually find a hotel and stay there overnight. We're kind of shell-shocked. Nobody really says much.
所以现在我妈决定我想我们可以走。所以我们走了。我们上了车，里克追着我们到车道。我们上了一辆车，只是在圣诞前夜凌晨1点开着，穿着睡衣，无处可去。我们最终找到了一个旅馆，在那里过了一夜。我们有点惊魂未定。没人说太多话。
We wake up in the morning and we go to the police station, because my mom needs to go get some things and we don't want to go there without police. Also there was a lot of presents. So we show up back at the house with the police escort, and they had turned the lights on on top of the car, which I thought was festive. And I don't know if you've ever gone into a house with a homicidal maniac and a police escort for your presents, but it's very different than coming down the stairs.
早上我们醒来，去警察局，因为我妈需要去拿一些东西，我们不想在没有警察的情况下过去。还有很多礼物。所以我们在警察护送下回到房子，他们打开了车顶上的灯，我觉得这很有节日气氛。我不知道你是否曾经在凶手和一个警察护送的情况下为了你的礼物进过一所房子，但这和走下楼梯完全不同。
So we collected our presents and put them in the trunk and drove away. We went to a Waffle House for breakfast. And normally if you told me, hey, you were going to spend Christmas morning at a Waffle House, I would be depressed. But after that night, I didn't care that the eggs weren't locally grown or whatever.
所以我们收集了礼物，把它们放在后备箱里开车走了。我们去一家Waffle House吃早餐。通常如果你告诉我，嘿，你要在Waffle House过圣诞早晨，我会很沮丧。但在那天晚上之后，我不在乎鸡蛋是不是本地种植的或者其他什么。
So we were sitting at breakfast, and it was then that I realized that I'd been going to Tennessee every year because I didn't want my mom to think that I'd abandoned her. I wanted her to think that in some way I was validating her choice, that I was encouraging her and her new life, even though I hated every decision she made. And it was after that Christmas Eve that I realized I had no more burden to go to Tennessee ever again. That was the best present I could have gotten.
所以我们坐在早餐桌旁，就在那时我意识到我每年都去田纳西州是因为我不希望我妈认为我抛弃了她。我希望她认为我在某种程度上是在肯定她的选择，我在鼓励她和她的新生活，尽管我讨厌她做的每一个决定。就在那个圣诞前夜之后，我意识到我再也没有负担去田纳西州了。那是我想得到的最好的礼物。
Thank you very much.
非常感谢。
Julian McCullough. His Comedy Central Presents special can be seen on his website, julianmccoullough.com.
朱利安·麦卡洛。他的Comedy Central Presents特别节目可以在他的网站julianmccoullough.com上看到。
One, two, three, four. [SINGING - "THE BEST CHRISTMAS SONG EVER"] It's Christmas time. And Baby, please don't come home. Not even if you want to. Because for you I've got no Christmas cheer. It's Christmas time. And, Baby, please don't come home, not even if you want to, not after what happened last year.
一，二，三，四。（唱歌——“有史以来最好的圣诞歌”）这是圣诞节。亲爱的，请不要回家。即使你想也不要。因为对你我没有圣诞节的欢乐。这是圣诞节。而且，亲爱的，请不要回家，即使你想也不要，在去年发生那件事之后。
Our program was produced today by Jane Feltes, Seth Lind, and me, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Lisa Pollak, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Senior Producer for our show is Julie Snyder. Emily Condon's our Office Manager. Production help from Shawn Wen.
我们的节目今天由简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）、塞斯·林德（Seth Lind）和我制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）、萨拉·科尼格（Sarah Koenig）、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、艾丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）。我们节目的资深制片人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。艾米丽·康顿（Emily Condon）是我们的办公室经理。肖恩·温（Shawn Wen）协助制作。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（鸣谢）
[SINGING] It's Christmas time, and baby please don't come home. Not even if you want to. Not after what happened last year. Yeah, I know, you're already thinking to yourself, wait, what do you mean, Dave? What happened last year? Well, I'm so glad you asked, Karen! Why don't I just refresh your memory?
（唱歌）这是圣诞节，亲爱的请不要回家。即使你想也不要。在去年发生那件事之后。是的，我知道，你已经在想了，等一下，你是什么意思，戴夫？去年发生了什么？嗯，我很高兴你问了，凯伦（Karen）！为什么我不刷新你的记忆呢？
It was Christmas Eve, and all our friends and family came over to the house. And yes, Karen, I know it wasn't my house. I don't own a house, Karen. And I guess that makes me not a real person or something, right? Anyway, so the doorbell rings, and guess who it is? It's Karen, everybody's favorite. Only it's not just you at the door. There's some guy with you, too. Some guy in a dumb sweater.
那是圣诞前夜，我们所有的朋友和家人都来到家里。是的，凯伦，我知道那不是我的房子。我不拥有房子，凯伦。我想这使我不是一个真正的人或者其他什么，对吧？不管怎样，门铃响了，猜猜是谁？是凯伦，大家的最爱。只是不仅是你站在门口。还有个家伙和你在一起。某个穿着愚蠢毛衣的家伙。
And you walk in and you're all like, Merry Christmas, everybody. I'd like everyone to meet my boyfriend, Don. And naturally, I can't help but think to myself, well that's strange. I thought I was Karen's boyfriend. Who the hell is Don? And so I just decided to go ahead and say it out loud. I said, well that's strange. I thought I was Karen's boyfriend. Who the hell is Don?
你走进来，你们都像，圣诞快乐，大家。我想让大家认识一下我的男朋友，唐（Don）。自然地，我忍不住心想，嗯那很奇怪。我以为我是凯伦的男朋友。唐是谁？所以我决定直接说出来。我说，嗯那很奇怪。我以为我是凯伦的男朋友。唐是谁？
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. Every day between now and Christmas, you will find him where he always is this time of year, at the downtown store of Marshall Fields in Chicago or whatever they call it now on Santa's lap. Go there yourself. Find him and he'll tell you himself,
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。WBEZ管理监督我们的节目由我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生负责。从现在到圣诞节的每一天，你会发现他都在这一年中的这个时候他在的地方，在芝加哥的马歇尔菲尔德（Marshall Fields）市中心商店或者现在不管他们叫什么，坐在圣诞老人的膝盖上。你自己去那里。找到他，他会亲自告诉你，
Yep. There's no one else who comes here as much as me. You can ask the manager. They let me keep stuff in the bathroom sometimes.
是的。没有其他人像我来得这么频繁。你可以问经理。他们有时让我把东西放在洗手间里。
I'm Ira Glass. I'm back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。我下周回来带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
And you know Karen, even though I'm pretty much the manliest guy I know, I'm not made of stone. So right then and there I couldn't help but burst into tears. And what do you do when the floodgates open? You just offer me a tissue like Michael Douglas in the hit movie Wall Street , after he punches Charlie Sheen right in the nose. Well, I'll tell you what, Karen, you might as well have punched me right in the nose, because you already stepped on my heart. Go ahead, Karen. Punch me in the nose. See what I care!
你知道凯伦，即使我是我认识的最强壮的男人，我也不是石头做的。所以就在那时，我忍不住泪流满面。当你打开闸门时你做什么？你只是递给我一张纸巾，像迈克尔·道格拉斯在热门电影《华尔街》里那样，在他打了查理·辛的鼻子之后。嗯，我会告诉你一件事，凯伦，你还不如直接打我的鼻子，因为你已经踩在了我的心上。继续，凯伦。打我的鼻子。看我管不管！
It's Christmas time, and baby please don't come home. Unless of course maybe you kind of feel like it, because Karen, I still love you. Still love you. I still love you. I still love you. Thank you, good night.
这是圣诞节，亲爱的请不要回家。除非当然也许你有点想，因为凯伦，我仍然爱你。仍然爱你。我仍然爱你。我仍然爱你。谢谢，晚安。
[APPLAUSE]
（掌声）
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。